und wir gehen eigentlich direkt weiter
zu alexander keller in berlin und steht
auf der straße das heißt nicht dass er
dort schlecht steht sondern er steht ein
bisschen zwischen den politischen
fronten denn er berichtet für uns über
die fdp und auch über die afg aber die
afg ist heute extrem viel interessanter
weil sie natürlich ein großer
wahlgewinner ist sie konnte ihren wert
verdoppeln das haben wir schon gelernt
aber sie wird damit nicht viel anfangen
können oder vielleicht doch
ja wir stehen hier auf der straße ist
auch ziemlich kalt hier in berlin
allerdings wird zumindest ja den
fdp-politikern warm ums herz wenn sie an
den gestrigen tag denken und bei uns ist
der bundessprecher einer der beiden
bundesvorsitzenden erneuten von der fdp
wollten
ich bin sicher sie haben den sieg in
thüringen gutgeheißen aber eingefahren
hat ihn ja ihr rivale björn höckel der
ja schon im sommer angekündigt hat der
jetzt amtierende bundesvorstand der wird
nicht mehr lange im amt bleiben er wird
dort alles auf den kopf stellen
diese drogen galt wahrscheinlich vor
allen dingen ihnen sehen sie diesen
wahlsieg in thüringen mit einem
lachenden und einem weinenden auge
und eigentlich sind weil sie sich
wirklich mit einem lachenden auge
eingefahren hat ihn das sagt auch wie
ein hacker selbst der landesverband
thüringen unter seiner leitung unter
assistenz der gesamtpartei wie das immer
ist in allen wahlkämpfen und die haben
da ein richtig schönes grandioses
ergebnis eingefahren dass er mehr als
eine verdoppelung der stimmen und die
freude darüber ist auch bei mir
ungeteilt was jetzt die äußerung von
haacke in leinefelde anbelangt er ist ja
völlig frei darin zu kandidieren und wir
sind eine partei dieses
basisdemokratisch ich bin ein großer
freund des wettbewerbs wenn es jetzt wie
ein höcker gelistet bei der
bundesvorstand zu kandidieren dann
begrüße ich das dann sollte das tun
es gibt ja nicht nur persönliches gibt
auch sachliche differenzen zwischen ihn
und hoffe sie sind zb in der sozial- und
rentenpolitik vor allem marktliberalen
ansatz dass hinten die betroffenen oft
nicht goutieren hätte er sozial populist
er möchte einen rentenbonus nur für
deutsche geben das klingt nicht sehr
verfassungskonform
wie wollen sie dieses duell mit ihm
trotzdem gewinnen
ich sehe das gar nicht als ein duell wir
haben ein gemeinsames ziel das ziel ist
eine gute versorgung unserer menschen im
alter derer die viele jahrzehnte
gearbeitet haben dass die angemessenen
eben einen alten auskommen im alter
haben wird erscheint unsere ziele
überhaupt nicht in der finanzierung
unterscheiden wir uns das ist wahr
da haben einen dissenz der darf aber
auch sein da finden längst interne
gespräche statt um das zu einer
vernünftigen position zusammenzuführen
ich füge mal an ich beschäftige mich mit
der frage nicht seit gestern sondern
seit reichlich dem vierteljahrhundert
weiß wovon ich spreche
und ich habe in gremiensitzungen noch
jeden überzeugen können dass wir den
ansatz nicht irgendein cooler
neoliberaler unfug ist sondern sehr wohl
durchdacht ist und ich glaube dass wir
da zwischen kurz und langfristigen
konzeption unterscheiden müssen dass wir
da auch zusammenfinden werden
kalbitz urbanen höcke drei
spitzenkandidaten die folge hatten bei
den wahlen in brandenburg in sachsen und
jetzt in thüringen ist die afd
nach dieser stärkung des sogenannten
flügels auf den weg zu einer
rechtsnationalistischen zu einer
völkischen partei wird höcke den
durchmarsch warten in braunschweig auf
den bundesparteitag sie die afg danach
anders aus als vorher
also zunächst mal normal ob top gear und
hecke kandidiert oder nicht mehr so wie
anne frank ich habe auch anders machen
er kann auch spontan kandidieren auch
dagegen gibt gibt es überhaupt keine
einwände entscheidend sondern dass die
delegierten und dann sehr wo die
mehrheitsverhältnisse sind da ist nichts
was mich irgendwie mit furcht erfüllte
oder oder ähnliches das ein ganz
normales parteileben und es gibt
natürlich auch unterschiedliche ansätze
jetzt haben sie selbst gesagt dass die
die positionen in der rentenpolitik von
ihm wenn sie in das klassische rechts
links kontinuum gehen eher links sind
andere positionen sind sind eher rechts
dann merken sie dass das diesem
kontinuum eigentlich ausgedient hat
dieses diese alte links rechts schema
das stimmt so nicht und wir müssen
einfach in braunschweig sehen wo die
mehrheitsverhältnisse sind
ich selbst weiß dass ich dass ich in
ruse maß an unterstützung in einer
partei habe und sehe das völlig gelassen
flüge von haacke ein verdachtsfall für
den verfassungsschutz da geht es gibt es
jetzt gerüchte oder informationen dass
der versuch die gemäßigteren
west landesverbände aus denen sie
aufstanden zu unterwandern zu spalten
ist das richtig nein das dass das ist
glatter unfug
es ist das ganz normale ringen um
positionen und sind sie mal setzten sich
die einen manchmal die anderen es ist
unübersehbar so dass in den ostdeutschen
landesverbänden der flügel den stärkeren
position hat als zum beispiel in
nordrhein westfalen da waren jetzt
unlängst landesvorstands war da haben
auch etliche medienvertreter gesagt da
macht den flügeln durchmarsch wenn sie
sich den landesvorstand anschauen dann
ist da tatsächlich nicht ein einziger
flügler reingekommen
in hessen sind auch nur zwei von neun
landesvorstandsmitglied und mentor dem
flügel durch zu rechnen uns ist es vom
landesverband zum landesverband
unterschiedlich und man muss ein stück
weit auch die größe der landesverbände
berücksichtigen wenn sie also den
nordrhein westfälischen landesverband
vergleiche mit dem thüringischen dann
sind da ganz erhebliche
größenunterschiede wie sie wissen
soweit jörg morton der bundessprecher
der afg einer der beiden bundessprecher
den wir etwas kälte zumuten mussten
heute morgen und so weit wie gesagt das
interview
er liebe zuschauer um 14 uhr 30 gibt es
die pressekonferenz der bundesspitze
jörg menten alexander gauland und wir
haben heute hier in der
bundespressekonferenz mit deren sicht
auf die wahl in thüringen das war es
jetzt hier von einem straßenecke in
berlin mit
zurück zur stephan kulle ins bonner
studio